mich hat heute eine meldung quasi auf
gerecht wonach die bundesnetzagentur den
verbrauchern jetzt erlaubt oder eine
möglichkeit eindruck anhand bestimmter
kriterien weniger zu bezahlen an den
internetanbieter wenn dem wenn der nicht
die
vertraglich vereinbarten die leistung
bringen ja das finde ich sehr im sinne
von verbraucherschutz haben wenn ein
bäcker mir
fünf brötchen versprochen hat und dafür
liefert dann will ich auch nur vier
bezahlen noch nicht vor aber
viel wichtiger ist da kontext wir
befinden uns ja heute in einem
wettlauf um fortschritte in der
digitalen transformation im
internationalen china indien
europa amerika und und alle länder
versuchen sich ja in dieser digitalen
transformation zu zu profilieren sich
vorteile zu erarbeiten sich neue
wohlstands chance zu erarbeiten kreativ
neuer arbeitsplätze so und wir
unterhalten uns jetzt über eine art
schadensbegrenzung wenn jemand weniger
liefert dann darf man was machen ich
will eine andere diskussion haben ich
will ich will eine diskussion haben
darüber dass es neue angebote gibt dass
mehr daten menge zur verfügung stehen
also was sich wünscht was ich hier wenn
ich war das bayern fahre ohne immobilien
zum glück hat telefonieren kann dass man
in der bahn freundlich mit dem internet
arbeiten ganz und ähnliches mehr so und
jetzt sind auch noch einige
studien aktuelle studien veröffentlicht
worden wonach deutschland im ranking der
digitale wettbewerbsfähigkeit
innerhalb der g7 staaten auf dem
vorletzten platz steht und innerhalb der
g20 staaten auf dem 3 jetzt sag ich da
führende volkswirtschaft europas das
kann doch nicht unser anspruch sein also
woran man ist
ich kann mit dem positive nachricht erst
mal haben wir haben tausende unternehmen
in deutschland kleine mittlere ganze die
natürlich längst die digitale
transformation auf ihre fahnen
geschrieben haben die riesige
fortschritte erzielen wie auch schon
einen eine
veränderungsbereitschaft
leben und und einen wichtigen
mentalitätswandel haben weil sie wissen
wenn sie digital sich nicht
transformieren dann sie ineffizient sein
dass sie nicht mehr wettbewerb warum
springt dieser geist sozusagen gestellt
das ja nicht auf den staat und seine
institutionen über ja weil der staat und
das muss ich einfach sagen in den
letzten jahren
einfach auffallend führungsschwach
ergebnis arm und mutlos diese digitale
transformation vorangetrieben hat weil
der staat schon der fall
ich sage der wirtschaft und die
digitalisierung die forscher das macht
ja auch aus eigeninteresse ja so und
jetzt muss der staat und damit wir
können ja nur beurteilen für das wasser
wirklich verantwortlichen ist nämlich
den digital digitale transformation im
öffentlichen raum also ich nenne
öffentliche verwaltung ich nenne
gesundheitswesen ich werde digitale
bildung ich nenne ich nenne schnell
netzausbau ich nenne rahmenbedingungen
für start-ups und für viele der
vorbereiter vortag die situation ist
noch viel schlimmer etwas haben gesagt
'für g20 trägerplatte werden wir auf
platz 17 kann man sagen mit platz im
klingt nicht so gut aber die wahrheit
ist viel schlimmer wenn du es wird
quartalsmäßig gemessen wie unsere
infrastruktur die digitale im globalen
wettbewerb aller länder auch ja da sind
wir gerade auf platz 63 hinter moldan
und paraguay und das muss man sehen also
wir sind nicht irgendwie schlecht wir
sind wirklich mich dann lasst uns die
letzten drei vier minuten nutzen wie wie
wenden wird ist also politik würde jetzt
sagen wir brauchen ein digital muss
million ministerium ein digitalisierungs
ministerium ist ein guter anfang oder
nur kulisse bereich nein ist wir müssen
es kapitalistisch lösen im sinne des
wortes kapital muss er muss investiert
werden diese branche von den 100 größten
digitale unternehmen der welt ist noch
eines europäisch das ist sap die
amerikaner erdrücken uns digital tische
mit dieser kapital macht weil sie sich
damit die systeme kaufen die märkte
kaufen die strukturen kaufen der
erfolgreichste unternehmer unserer
generation heißt tobias ist ein netter
mann aus koblenz der immer mit einem
schäfer mit herumläuft kennt in
deutschland kein mensch ist ein
superstar der weltwirtschaft ja das
unternehmen shop ev gegründet ist
übrigens 200 milliarden euro wird mehr
als jeder dax-konzern ein ganz junger
mann einen digitalen konzert ein coupé
jetzt mal von der digitalisierung des
öffentlichen raum in der staat muss eine
vorbildfunktion einnehmen für die
gesellschaft und je lama die digitale
transformation in der verwaltung in der
bildung was ja aufwartet wie ich denn
das ja die größte deutschland ja weil
digitale bildung nämlich die
chancengerechtigkeit erweitert du musst
nicht nur von torres ist ein internat
gehen um spitzen lernstoff zu krieg das
kasseler weise über den laptop auch
bekommen und die schulen haben noch
nicht mal villa ja ganz ganz genau was
das haben alle und und ich glaube das
ist nur zu lösen wie gesagt lösen mit
durchregieren also es muss ein
gesegneter daran ist
also super ministerin es muss eine du
einbringen eine priorisierung gesetz für
die digitale transformation
es muss dann so geführt werden auch ich
sage mal ein bisschen autoritär dass
eine solche quasi revolution richtig
durchgeführt werden kann und da muss
wichtiges von unwichtigem getrennt sein
da kann es dann einfach nicht wahr sein
dass eine eine bürgerinitiative von 50
verstrahlten esoterikern die gegen die
funkmasten hier demonstrieren dass die
dann den ausbau bis fünf gene zu stoppen
kann dann muss müssen wieder stellen wir
aus dem weg geräumt werden sonst kommen
wir nicht wer unsere leser immer im
laden blick also sozusagen einen
querschnitt durch deutschland gehen die
das mit die bürger ich glaube die würden
das wahnsinnig gerne mit gehen weil wir
in ihrem alltag gerade jetzt eine krone
krise gemerkt haben was alles nicht
funktioniert und dass der staat hat sich
einfach absolut lachnummer gemacht
erinnern wir uns doch mal an diese
rückkehr scheine die es gab wenn man
wenn man mit dem flugzeug zurück kam aus
dem urlaub im letzten sommer da kam dann
die stewardess hat einem so ein
papierchen in die hand gedrückt und dann
musste man zur kontakt nach ja
da hab ich mit politikern telefoniert
und die sagen mir auf jedem vierten
papier steht der name mickey mouse und
der stadt kann nichts dagegen tun und
ich glaube die bürger würden das liebend
gerne mitgehen aber wir haben gerade
schon über widerstände gesprochen was
ist eigentlich mit der
nach die eigentlichen guten job ist
design und dann ganz schnell wenn die
beeren der aktie wäre würden die kauft
ja klar ja ja ja ja ja nicht ich denke
ein wir dürfen ihre möglichkeiten nicht
überschätzen
verantwortliche kanzleramt für die er
die gitarre das problem dass sie nur
dort war sie hatte kein auto kein
italien auch wenn sie hat sie hat keine
armee die mal hier nach links oder nach
rechts mal hier marschieren kann aber
ich finde sie hat das thema
digitalisierung wenigstens in der
öffentlichen diskussion immer
glaubwürdig und kompetent vertreten
da standen sie haben die stand sie hat
auch ein handy und hab ich als wir
müssen schluss machen wir diskutieren
gleich per handy weiter sofern der
empfang klappt aber hier im haus und
hier im studio ist sei nicht ganz gut
[Musik]